finalmente quedaron dos resiste una
contra lis tras una batalla para
convertirse en el próximo primer
ministro o primera ministra de reino
unido el miércoles una carrera de tres
se redujo a dos luego de que penn y
morgan quedara fuera de la competencia
por el número 10 de downing street
un ex ministro de finanzas ha estado por
delante en todas las votaciones hasta
ahora pero éstas sólo se realizaron
entre compañeros parlamentarios
conservadores la votación final y
decisiva se abrirá a los miembros del
partido conservador lo que según las
proyecciones convertirá astros en la
favorita creo que lo otro que hay que
tener en cuenta en esta carrera es lo
inciertas que están las cosas en este
momento this tras parte ciertamente como
favorita pero hemos visto que los donde
os suben y bajan de forma bastante
dramática en las pocas semanas en las
que esta contienda ha estado activa
hasta ahora frost secretaria de asuntos
exteriores de reino unido es considerada
más popular que es una que entre los
afiliados y se ha consolidado como la
opción de la derecha ambos candidatos
accedieron a un debate ante una
audiencia en directo en skynews el
próximo 4 de agosto
la votación que concluirá el 5 de
septiembre permitirá al reino unido-
contar con su tercera mujer como primera
ministra o con el primer líder asiático
británico en su historia